e a inclusão tá muito além de um livre
baile
Olá eu sou Lucas paredes e antes de
começar a falar sobre esse tema eu
gostaria de fazer uma alto descrição
minha para que mais pessoas que são
deficientes visuais assim como eu tenho
mais acessibilidade Eu assisti esse
conteúdo é só homem branco uso barba
Estou vestindo uma camiseta preta calça
jeans e tenho cabelos longos presos para
trás por um arco
é a minha história começa 20 anos atrás
durante a meditação minha mãe teve uma
rubéola na gravidez que não foi
diagnosticada e fez funcionar seja uma
retina mal formada
é essa a gente é uma formada Ela só foi
apresentar algum tipo de problema quando
eu tinha 12 anos foi quando eu tive meu
primeiro descolamento de retina dos 2
aos 18 anos eu fiz ao todo 12 cirurgias
e com 18 anos no meio do segundo ano do
ensino médio que foi onde eu perdi a
maior parte televisão
e naquele momento eu não sabia muito bem
o que acontecer parecia que minha vida
tinha acabado ali e tudo tinha caiu o
mundo tinha caído para mim
oh ma esse processo de autoaceitação da
pessoa com deficiência ainda leva tempo
eu só ia descobrir que ele levava tempo
depois eu tivesse passado por ele esse
processo de autoaceitação ele começa a
gente tendo muita vergonha muito medo
muito receio do que as pessoas vão
pensar da gente e como que a gente vai
ser visto no mundo aí fora eu também
tinha isso E com o tempo eu fui
aprendendo a lidar com esse turbilhão de
emoções não foi fácil tiveram dias de
choro de tristeza de alegria também mas
conforme a gente vai ser alto aceitando
as coisas vão se tornando mais tranquila
a gente vai se adaptando a essa Nova
Condição que a gente tem com isso em
2016 eu voltei a estudar tava no
terceiro ano do ensino médio e eu fui
fazer o vestibular e
há 8 meses de ter perdido a visão eu já
tinha decidido que eu queria fazer
relações internacionais mas agora eu
procurava alguma Universidade que
tivesse cotas para pessoas com
deficiência porque eu pensava que
universidade que tivesse essa abertura
para a inclusão teria políticas de
inclusão e acessibilidade que tô na
reunião processo de ingresso no ensino
superior mais tranquilo e meia recebo
lento e mais acessível também claro
e eu fiz o Enem 2016 passei não SBC ele
foi uma mudança na minha vida
é muito pra influência familiar eu
também queria cursar uma universidade
pública meus pais ainda tinham muito
medo de como seria perguntas relatos de
falta de acessibilidade e inclusão mas
ela vai saber se ele é diferente quando
a gente vai fazer a matrícula em
fevereiro o choque foi geral ninguém
esperava que quando a gente chegasse até
um elevador com botões em Braile com e
com áudio e também eu não esperava que
quando eu fiz assim o piso vermelho no
Campus de Santo André da Universidade
fosse Tem um piso tátil a partir daquele
momento eu comecei a me sentir muito
mais excluído na universidade um piso
taco fez muita diferença na impressão
que eu tinha de como seria
é a minha trajetória no ensino superior
e eu mudei para São Paulo junto com a
família em maio e até o trote eu no
começo sempre quis notório no trote meus
pais ainda tinham muito medo de como
seria eles me perguntavam Tá mas como
você vai fazer eu falava eu não sei eu
só quero ir apesar do medo eu sempre
quis ir e pesquisando na internet
encontrei para o trote do SBC era um
trote humanizado é isso me deixa mais
tranquila Foi então que no dia nem que
seja em Maio de 2017 eu fui para o
trânsito tava um dia bem ensolarado eu
ainda tava com muito medo com muito
receio eu não sabia como que eu sei as
coisas mas eu fui tava com meus pais e
eu sei que lembrava muito uma frase
Minha mãe sempre me disse que a única
coisa que a vida esses da gente é
coragem e aquele dia apesar de todo o
medo que eu sentia eu tive coragem de ir
eu pensei é melhor eu ir porque eu não
quero ficar me perguntando o resto da
minha vida como teria sido se eu tivesse
ido
e naquele dia de sol Uns poucos digital
que faz em São Bernardo em na época de
Maio eu cheguei no câmpus eu tava com
uma mochila em depois aquele quebra
Jenice as veteranas eles eram em pintar
eu esperava ansiosamente para aquele
momento sempre que ser tentado e ela
memória visual que eu tinha ninguém
entrava na universidade olha aqui uma
das coisas mais legais você tá tudo sujo
no dia do Trote e pintado com a
segurança saudação a universidade EA
partir daquele momento que me apresentei
para os veteranos Eles vieram
perguntaram quem era que curso eu
gostaria de fazer como que eu tinha
entrado nessa vez e ele me perguntava a
gente pode pintar eu falei claro com
certeza e a partir do momento que aquele
pincel tocou na minha testa
e foi uma coisa muito simbólico é muito
poderosa eu me senti realmente incluído
na universidade por uma simples tinta
escrito usb-c Eu sabia que aqui de
representar uma mudança na mente do
Vitória de vidro de vida e apesar de uma
perda visual recente eu queria pelo
menos tentar aquele sonho já não sabia o
que ia acontecer mas eu entrei na
universidade
e logo que eu entrei uma das primeiras
coisas que me auxiliaram muito nesse
processo de ganho de autonomia de
confiança dentro do campus foi o
programa de monitoria da UFF ABC no
programa de muito aí é uma política de
inclusão do nome da sensibilidade onde
os próprios alunos veteranos se
voluntariam para acompanhar as pessoas
com deficiência nas aulas ajudando a se
locomover pela Universidade a conhecer
os lugares e também quando atenção de
material então essa parte de inclusão no
dia a dia da da faculdade mas problema é
o Senhor demais tu é através dele que eu
aprendi
e a decorar a ordem das salas os números
a entender como que era a lógica de
organização de todos os prédios do
campus e é muito engraçado porque quando
a gente não tem um sentido a gente passa
a estabelecer uma relação diferente com
os lugares que a gente está inserido eu
tenho uma relação dele aqui emocional
qual SBC não tá naquele canto para mim é
muito mais sentimentos muito bons porque
eu lembro de tudo que já passei já vivi
gente então a gente passa a contar os
passos a contar as duas e a reparar em
como Campos organizado nos desenhos nas
estruturas no Jardins em como as coisas
funcionam ele como é que é a dinâmica EA
rotina daquele espaço
e como as coisas mais interessantes foi
quando um dia eu estava parado em frente
a um dos blocos e ele tem portas e eu
pensava tá mas como é que eu vou entrar
sozinha aqui aí eu parei respirei e
ficava procurando por um barulho pressa
de som que indicasse que era por aí o
caminho uma série de outras técnicas a
gente vai aprendendo a desenvolver
e estando presente no campo que a gente
percebe o quão importante é ocupar esses
espaços da universidade
a ocupar o corredor é uma oportunidade
incrível da gente estabelecer diversas
relações isso foi aprender com tempo no
começo eu tinha muito medo e muita
vergonha de estar naquele corredor cheio
de gente com um monte de aluno e me
sentia meio perdido mas conforme foi
passando o tempo eu fui ocupando aquele
espaço entendendo que eu poderia pedir
ajuda o pedir licença que não teria
problema nenhum tem mais que isso aquele
espaço representava um lugar incrível
para eu ter ser novas relações encontrar
com os olhos amigos porque todo mundo já
se sentiu um pouco sozinho não SBC o
sistema é muito diferente a gente muda
muito de turma então único lugar que a
gente consegue realmente encontrar
pessoas que a gente entrou na
universidade que a gente conhece naquele
espaço do Corredor a queremos paz humano
e aonde ocupando aquele espaço a gente
consegue construir um monte de relações
novas
e em 2018 no processo de autoaceitação
já caminhava bem mais rápido eu tava
estagiando participando do movimento
estudantil ainda cursando a universidade
até que apareceu a oportunidade de eu ir
para Alemanha participar de um Congresso
Infantil com outros jovens com
deficiências representando o SBC eu não
sabia muito bem o que acontecer mas
assim como no trade eu fiz a inscrição
me joguei consegui passar nos testes em
agosto de 2018 eu tava embarcando no
avião com mais dois outros alunos a
universidade e dois técnicos
administrativos para passar uma semana
na Alemanha
e essa viagem foi o assentamento
trajetória na universidade eu jamais
imaginaria que um ano e meio depois de
eu ter ingressado e como a perda visual
tão recente eu vou ser a oportunidade de
viajar internacionalmente representando
ela acha vez e fora do país e ainda mais
em congresso aqui contar com a
participação de jovens com deficiência
de diversos lugares do mundo durante
essa viagem aí a postura já era muito
diferente da que eu tinha do Trote
aquele mesmo que começou a se esvair
quando aquele pincel tocou na minha
testa e sentou essa ABC ele ainda tava
ali mas ele já é muito menor
e nessa viagem eu sentia mais ansiedade
eu queria participar eu tava muito
ansioso para ver como que as coisas
seriam o meio que eu tinha era de não
conseguir falar falar inglês por exemplo
o meu deu comum mas deixar muita vontade
de conhecer o mundo de forma outono
E aí conversando durante essa semana com
esses jovens que estavam participando
nesse congresso a gente chegou numa não
com senso comum de que apesar de todas
as barreiras que ainda existiam e
existem no ensino superior uma texto era
muito comum a falta de inclusão em todos
os ambientes da vida social da
Universidade muitos deles falavam que a
gente que tinham acesso a material
adaptável às aulas mas que faltava ainda
se sentir se sentir pertencente
realmente aquela comunidade e isso muito
por conta da falta de inclusão nessa
vida social em todas as experiências são
Universidade pode nos proporcionar
eu voltar dessa viagem eu parei para
pensar e refletir sobre isso
Olá hoje nós pessoas com deficiência
somos um bilhão de pessoas do mundo mas
você não vê a gente por aí ocupando
todos os espaços possíveis e imagináveis
a nossa sociedade ainda muito
preconceituosa capacetes Ainda falta
muita inclusão e muita sensibilidade
diversos aspectos felizmente a gente nem
conseguindo avanços e Progressos na
agenda de inclusão mas conversando com
eles tentam experienciado todas essas
vivências
e eu percebi que faltava uma inclusão
com foco mais específico na vida social
enquanto um agente de transformação da
realidade daquela comunidade
a inclusão está muito além da sala de
aula justamente porque ter acesso ao
conhecimento e não baixo Praça
experienciar tudo que a universidade
pode nos proporcionar em sendo uma
pessoa com deficiência isso fica ainda
mais nítido que a gente percebe quantos
de nós se não tiver a oportunidade a
gerenciar uma viagem um trote participar
de um evento cultural de uma festa e
isso é muito importante sendo integrado
em todas as esferas possíveis e
imagináveis a vida social é que a gente
realmente percebe o com potente
e são as nossas possibilidades e o
quanto a gente pode ocupar esses espaços
e sempre protagonista nossa própria
história o que eu queria na verdade era
que para além de uma exceção à regra a
minha história força regra que qualquer
aluno que ingressaram no ensino superior
tivesse oportunidade de experienciar
tudo que ele quisesse de ter
sensibilidade é tudo que ele fizesse
isso só é possível com base em um
ambiente mais inclusivo e o processo de
autoaceitação que acontece demora mais
que é transformador e com políticas
públicas de inclusão e acessibilidade
que são realmente efetivas e que
realmente funciona então autonomia e
confiança da pessoa com deficiência
florais ocupar esses espaços
é uma frase que minha mãe sempre me
disse que eu sempre carreguei comigo ao
longo de toda essa vitória foi que a
única coisa que a vida da gente é
coragem e com base nisso eu fui
experienciando vivenciando essas
oportunidades dentro da universidade
Ah mas eu queria que todo mundo que quer
cursar o ensino superior que têm uma
deficiência tivesse a oportunidade de
realmente vivenciar por completo tudo
que a universidade pode nos proporcionar
sem nenhum tipo de barreira sem nenhum
tipo de preconceito sem nenhum tipo de
medo de se vai ou não ser incluído
porque já existe uma política que vai
cobrir a pessoa em todo tipo de
atividade que ela quiser fazer eu sou o
Lucas para eles e essa minha história
obrigado tá